chalk one up for the good guys two
months after leftist cry bully Carlos
masa tried to get steven crowder and
other conservatives thrown off of
YouTube it looks like voxcom is firing
him we talked yesterday about how
conservatives should react to the
political misfortunes of our political
foes and of course we should extend an
olive branch even to Carlos Massa even
to leftists who relentlessly seek to
smear and silenced us tomorrow today
however we should laugh in his face
hahahahaha we win you lose Carlos Meza
ha ha
we will analyze what boxes move means
for 2020 particularly in light of a
Google whistleblowers latest document
dumped on the tech giant's political
interference efforts then sex trafficker
and cartoonish supervillain Jeffrey
Epstein's autopsy reveals broken bones
in his neck that are more consistent
with homicide than suicide hmm we will
examine for any Clinton's watching why
he still totally committed suicide and
this is all perfectly normal
and I don't know nothing I don't know
nothing I tell you then a quick look at
20/20 finally the mailbag I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
excellent news coming out of voxcom
that's the first time I've ever said
that statement but there is excellent
news and it's it's even good news for
big tech in 2020 we'll get to that in a
second but first I have got to thank an
excellent sponsor wonderful supporter of
the show and a company that I have used
for well over 10 years now I am talking
about Vistaprint because I it took me a
while to learn this lesson
your next big big opportunity is coming
up you feel it you're totally ready to
go and then you don't have a business
card you're there this has happened to
me so many times in my life I'm at an
event I'm networking I talk to somebody
who's really important I want to give
them my information they said you have a
card and I say I know because I'm a
little child I'm just I'm sorry I'm a
little irresponsible child can I write
it for you on a napkin no you're not
interested okay in there there goes the
opportunity right now you can have your
big opportunity all it takes to feel
like you're ready to own the now is 10
bucks Vistaprint is the only company
that I have used for my personal
business cards and I've used them
forever long before the daily wire
existed for 10 bucks
vistaprint gives you 500 personalized
cards with exactly the look that you
want that is a low price to make a
lasting impression they are great
quality they are totally reliable you
can choose the colors fonts designs
images means you can create something as
unique and compelling as your business
as if you needed any more reasons to
choose Vistaprint you can feel good
knowing that vistaprint users only
carefully selected inks and responsibly
sourced paper stocks your satisfaction
is 100% guaranteed or your money back
and I can tell you this because there
have been times we've made mistakes or
things you know some tiny did to order
them earlier than I did and vistaprint
has always worked with me all the whole
step of the way it's an incredible value
it's it's a great product they're just
the best Vistaprint wants you to be able
to own the now in any situation that's
why they are giving our listeners 500
high quality custom business cards
starting at just $9.99 go to
vistaprint.com slash mobile scanner wles
vistaprint.com slash Knolls get 500
custom business cards and own the now
vistaprint.com
slash Knolls real
great product really great news coming
out of voxcom two and a half months
after Carlos masa tried to get Crowder
and other conservatives and obviously
they were looking down the pike at us
trying to take them all off of youtube
it appears it's being reported right now
that Carlos masa is being fired from
voxcom if you do not remember this in
sufferable leftist bully here he is so
he was saying was not had nothing to do
with my political views he was calling
me a list B queer and a spry and a fairy
and he called me a gay Mexican and she
would have routinely make fun of the way
that I spoke and just do gay impressions
he made kind of gruesome sexual comments
about me I hope that YouTube recognizes
that the end result of this is not some
happy medium it's a place where only
bullies operate if the teacher never
intervenes the kids were getting bullied
the playground will leave with a
playground and that's what's happening
to YouTube
truer words have never been spoken
that's right the bullies look it looked
like the bullies were gonna just run the
whole internet at the bullies of course
not being steven crowder the bullies
being this jerk who's trying to silence
all of his political opponents he was
angry at crowder for calling him gay and
queer do you know what this guy's
personally selected twitter handle is
gay walk he calls himself gay all the
time he calls himself queer all the time
by the way we've been told that queer is
the new politically correct term it's in
the acronym LGBTQ used not only by gay
people themselves but also by straight
politicians but only only the good ones
only they'll let the progressive ones
can use the term the conservative ones
if you use it it's the same as the
n-word I guess everything's the n-word
these days
gay is the n-word queer as the n-word
fredo is the n-word I think the n-word
is still the n-word outrageous stuff
trying to get us all kicked off now it
looks like he's going down according to
reports this was one of the first media
guys to call Tucker Carlson a white
supremacist I mean in many ways
Carlos Maz is ahead of his time he is
kind of leading the progressive
political tactics he had in his Twitter
bio Tucker Carlson is a white
supremacist he referred to himself as a
Marxist now all the 20 20 Democratic
presidential candidates are not only
calling Tucker Carlson a white
supremacist they're calling if
all of the Trump supporters half of the
country conservatives and Republicans
referring to them as white nationalists
and white supremacists so I think Carlos
maza I mean I gotta give give the devil
his due he recognized that the way that
Democrats can avoid what happened in
2016
really the best way if not the only way
that the left and Democrats can avoid
the re-election of Donald Trump and
keeping keep on losing their races is by
censoring their opponents that's the way
the way to do it is because the left
controls the flow of information around
the internet because all of the big tech
companies are decidedly invariably
leftist the way that they can do it is
by censoring us shutting us up
ruthlessly silencing conservatives on
the Internet and apparently this was too
much even for Vox Carlos maza flew a
little bit too close to the Sun and I
think this is the right move for Vox to
fire him the reason being I called this
at the time I said it's a bad look for a
media company to censor their opponents
it's a bad look for an outlet and news
outlet in a commentary outlet to be
trying to silence and censor other
people because it it you just look like
such a hypocrite you know the Republic
dies in darkness democracy dies in
darkness by the way we need to darken
the office buildings of every single one
of our competitors doesn't look good I
mean and the left also has operative
organizations that exist to silence
conservatives and to get all of us fired
they have Media Matters so they don't
even need voxcom to fill that gap I
think as a business decision as a
journalistic decision they had to fire
this guy but this ties in with what
we're talking about over here at Google
I mean I'm really glad that Carlos maza
is going down I am really glad that the
timing works to prove my rule yesterday
the rule I said yesterday is I don't
want to jump on Fredo Cuomo for having a
couple drinks and defending his honor at
a restaurant or a beer garden or
wherever he was I don't want to jump on
Don Lemon because of just some
allegations in a lawsuit I want to wait
for the evidence I want to be measured I
want to be reasonable I don't want
people to be fired I don't want to send
my political opponents but the left
won't play by those rules and there is
nothing moral there is nothing nice
there is nothing high minded about
unilaterally disarming and letting the
left destroy our culture and politics
there's nothing good about that I think
there are some conservatives who think
that by remaining above it all and not
engaging with political realities saying
well I'm never going to get my hands
dirty that that's somehow good that
somehow is virtuous or moral it's not
there's nothing good about about letting
guys like Carlos masa totally destroy
our culture and our government in our
politics so I'm I'm glad that we have
two that we're getting into this I'm
glad that this guy's going down and I
would be happy to extend grace to my
political opponents as the right has
regularly done but they need to extend
grace to us three times in a row just
three times in a row some some non
traversée comes up some tweet or
something some you know they can go
after of Sean Hannity or Tucker Carlson
or one of us or I don't know they can
they could go after one of us and they
choose not to if they do that once
that's a good start they do it a second
time fine if they do it three times I'm
willing to extend grace to the left
until they do that three times in a row
and by the way I'm not just talking
about random Twitter accounts or
something I'm talking about that these
these guys voxcom is a huge outlet on
the left the the people who are out
there forward facing the 2020 Democratic
presidential candidates if they extend
grace three times in a row will extend
grace to them if they don't we're gonna
laugh in Carlos Mazdas face hah hah hah
hah hah hah hah hah hah hah hah hah
we'll see what this means for big tech
generally we'll see what it means for
2020 and of course we got to get to the
latest in the epstein saga but first I
have got to tell you about one of my
favorite new products liquid IV liquid
IV well maybe you've never heard of it
before
write it down remember this name I
actually I used liquid IV just this
morning last night I went out had a
couple adult beverages with a pal of
mine
couple Coca Cola's you know I wanted to
make sure that I wasn't feeling sluggish
this morning because I knew that I had
to bring you the most energetic best
show that I possibly could
liquid IV is the secret it's the fastest
most efficient way to stay hydrated if
you're trying to drink more water liquid
IV hydrates you two to three times
faster and more efficiently than water
alone with an added bonus of vitamin C
b3 b5 b6 and b12 now a lot of people
would use this for athletics you know if
you're you're trying to replenish
yourself you're trying to hydrate faster
obviously that's not me I'm not the most
athletic guy in the world I'm not
exactly an Olympic athlete so what I use
it for is my favorite hobbies are
smoking cigars and having a few drinks
with the friends and it works very well
for that latter activity too because
sometimes if you're going out and you're
dehydrating yourself you don't feel
great in the morning there is a better
way than just feeling bad and trying to
chug water or something like that do it
liquid IV it's the fastest-growing
wellness brand you can find them
everywhere even Costco you can find
their hydration multiplier sold at all
cost goes nationwide liquid IV can
provide the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water so if
you're a derelict like me you can have
it after a long night out or a bachelor
party or something if you're you know
sort of a good person you can use it
when you're out camping you can use it
when you're doing sports you can use it
for the kids if you're at you know if
kids are running around and playing out
on a hot summer day you can use it for
yourself I mean it's just fabulous I
really love it you will too right now my
listeners get 25% off at liquid IV comm
when you use my code Noel's canna wles
at checkout that is 25% off anything you
order on liquid Ivy's website go to
liquid IV comm and enter my promo code
Knolls canada wles to get your savings
and start getting better hydration
liquid IV dot-com promo code Knowles
don't wait start properly hydrating
today do not wait so this ties in with
what we're talking about on big tech
generally there's a whistleblower from
Google that just came out thanks to
Project Veritas and James O'Keefe the
whistleblowers name is Zachary Voorhees
war High's he delivered nearly a
thousand pages of documents to the
Department of Justice's Antitrust
Division demonstrating they
Google manipulated its algorithms in
such a way that it biased its search
engine results against conservatives
against Republicans against Christians
all the people who were politically
incorrect these days Google was actively
going out of their way to suppress them
here's the whistleblower I felt that our
entire election system was going to be
compromised forever by this company that
told the American public that it was not
going to do any evil this is the best
thing that I can do in the situation
that I'm currently at so this guy's
coming out he's revealing his face he's
revealing his voice he's not even using
one of those masks or anything like that
he's coming up because he said that this
was compromising our election system
this is the greatest irony of the last
three years of Russian collusion and the
illegitimate election because the
Democrats can't ever admit that they
lost a presidential election they
accused Republicans of cheating on the
election there is no evidence that that
happened whatsoever not a zilch nothing
the left however did interfere in the
election they did manipulate the
election they did skirt FEC rules
because they don't need to point out
that when you have the largest companies
that control the flow of Internet
Internet information when you have them
working for one side of the political
aisle that is obviously an in-kind
contribution that is worth millions and
millions and millions of dollars if not
more and they get to do it that is the
election interference how do they do it
they hit us from several angles they
first of all they control the flow of
information around the internet Google
in particular Google is search that's it
they've tried to make other search
companies Google is search right they do
it when they don't just do it on Google
they do it on Facebook they do it on
Twitter
obviously they do it on YouTube YouTube
is owned by Google Google owns the
Internet so they control the flow of
information if they want if there's a
story they don't want getting around
they can suppress it and they regularly
do one thing they did to us for a while
is when you'd search for Daily wire
you'd get a bunch of results of leftist
organizations talking about how terrible
we are those would be some of the first
results
come up so you google it you say okay I
wanted to hear about this story and say
oh I can't trust daily wire because the
organizations that Google is promoting
don't like us so they control the
information how else do they hit you
they have all of your data that Google
owns your data so every little thing
you've ever typed in every little weird
search that you've put into that browser
you know what I'm talking about I know
you look at some weird stuff on the
Internet
talking about stuff like the Michael
Knowles show I'm talking about stuff
like daily wire.com you look at some
weird stuff maybe you don't want that to
get out there because you can lose your
job in your reputation that is owned by
Google it's not there are no protections
on that it's not like that's owned by
the government there might not be
protections on on it even if it were but
it's just a random corporation a super
powerful corporation a very leftist
corporation that hates everything that
you believe not a good situation to be
in is it and then they can manipulate
the appearance of reality itself this
brings us to a deep fakes I mean this is
we'll get to deep fakes in a second but
that is too much power Google has too
much power that's it they can alter our
elections they can manipulate your data
they have total leverage over you and
what you think and all your deepest
darkest secrets and all your financial
information and everything photos of you
and now they can manipulate the
appearance of reality itself I love the
deep fake story I mean it's very if you
haven't looked at deep fakes the New
York Times is warning about it they say
deep fakes are coming we can no longer
believe what we see this came out in the
New York Times there is now technology
that can so manipulate video that you
can't even believe your own eyes we'll
get to that in a second we'll get to the
negative side of that what that means
for us and our privacy and our politics
we'll also get to maybe a silver lining
in all of that but first I have to thank
our friends at expressvpn talk about
perfect timing to thank expressvpn if
you can't trust certain elements in
Silicon Valley to treat conservatives
fairly how can you trust them
to handle your privacy and your personal
online data duh I mean you know these
guys are out to get you so that is why I
recommend using expressvpn every time
you go online I know you're lazy you
think they don't want my info oh who
cares it's not gonna affect me stop it
stop at big tech companies can use your
IP address to match your internet
activity to your identity or your
location when I use Express VPN search
engines and media sites cannot see my IP
address at all my identity is masked its
anonymized that's a good thing
expressvpn has the added benefit of
encrypting 100% of your data to keep you
safe from people who you don't want to
have your data namely all the people who
currently can see what you're doing
Express VPN software it takes one minute
to set up on your computer or phone you
tap one button and you're protected
that's it I know look I'm kind of lazy
when it comes to my tech and my security
and all the things I'm supposed to do
don't compromise on your data and don't
allow your data to be compromised your
internet data belongs to you it
shouldn't belong to giant tech companies
that are not friendly to you and not
friendly to what you believe expressvpn
is the answer you can protect your
online activity today with the VPN I
trust to keep my data safe visit
expressvpn com / Michel mi CH AE L to
claim an exclusive offer for our
listeners expr ESS VPN dot-com / Michael
mi CH AE l that is three months free
with a one-year package not going to get
that anywhere else
expressvpn comm / michael mi CH AE l to
get started go do it don't wait deep
fakes actually kind of take us to the
logical conclusion of this big tech
behemoth so if you haven't seen or heard
a deep fake check this one out this is a
deep fake of Barack Obama looks almost
exactly like him frankly it sounds
almost exactly like him - we're entering
an era in which our enemies can make it
look like anyone is saying anything at
any point in time even if they would
never say those things so for instance
they could have me say things like
I don't know kill monger was right or
ben Carson is in the sunken place or how
about this simply President Trump is a
total and complete dip now you see I
would never say these things at least
not in a public address but someone else
would someone like Jordan Peele there
there it is you can see it's Jordan
Peele there and he is the one who's just
coming up with all of this monologue I
mean it's just a comedian and he's
coming up with this monologue the voice
isn't perfect but if the voice were a
little bit better it would be
indistinguishable because on the video
features the Obama's face it you you
almost it's 99.9% you couldn't tell that
it's a fake video and there's a lot of
alarm people are freaking out over this
because net talk about future dystopia
now you can't even believe what you see
someone some big tech giant could just
make a fake video and you wouldn't be
able to separate the real video from
reality I mean we're within like two
years of these being and pretty much
perfect I actually think it's a pretty
good thing I think this is helpful to
conservatives I think this is helpful to
taking down some of this tyranny of big
tech everything today is on photo or on
video everything everything you did the
coffee you had this morning the walk you
took with your dog your drive while you
were instagramming a story as you were
driving and you know also recording
something else and also everything is
out there and this is especially true
for a generation that grew up with
Facebook I was kind of right at the
beginning of that we we finally got
Facebook when I was in eighth or ninth
grade I think and that was kind of the
new thing before that we had MySpace
before that we had xanga before that we
had live journal so people were all
uploading their photos and their
information and now you have a whole
generation that didn't exist without
those kind of companies everything is up
there so I remember at the time we're in
high school I was thinking gosh
people run for office in 20 or 30 years
from this generation we're gonna have
every we're gonna know everything they
ever did we're gonna know every beer
they had in high school we're gonna know
every rule they broke we're gonna know I
mean we're gonna know everything about
them what is that going to mean for
politicians who often are guarded who
guard their privacy the question you
have to ask yourself is what do those
photos and videos really tell us the
best example is that grab them by that
you know what video the Access Hollywood
tape that came out in 2016 this video
this was going to end Trump's
presidential campaign people shocked and
condemnation everywhere because Trump
was caught on a hot mic having this
private exchange locker room talk with
Billy Bush saying yeah these girls when
you're a star they let you do whatever
you want to him I don't know I just kiss
him I just grabbed him by the whatever
what did that video show us what did it
actually tell us about Trump it told us
that Trump is a celebrity yep
true told us that Trump is a womanizer
he likes he likes women I'm not saying
he's a woman abuser I'm saying he enjoys
the company of women and has dated many
many women while he was married while he
wasn't married we already knew that that
was all over the tabloids for 30 years
tells us that Trump has a little bit of
a naughty mouth while he's talking with
the boys ostensibly in private obviously
we knew that he's got a dirty mouth in
public what did it tell us that was knew
nothing but there was this shock of
seeing it on video because the visual is
so much more compelling than just the
argument you know this is why this is
why politicians have television ads this
is why they make produce video this is
why it's all about the style it's why
they spend so much time manicuring their
image it's because the images strike is
so much more to our core than merely
arguments this is why Hollywood is so
incredibly successful and manipulating
our culture that's why not just leftist
culture in the United States but it's
actually why the United States has used
Hollywood in film as a tool of what is
what is called on the Left cultural
imperialism what we're doing this work
sporting our culture and exerting soft
influence around the world
now you can't quite trust the video you
know if this if trumpet
for office in ten years from now he
could say oh it's a fake video it's fake
it's a deep fake now it we know it's a
real video because it happened ten or
fifteen years ago but he could say that
and I think that's a very good thing I'm
actually kind of all for it
I I think that we should focus in our
politics on what's going on now on
things that actually matter obviously
you want to know the character of the
guys that you're electing but I don't
care that he said some naughty word on
tape fifteen years ago it could have an
outsized effect on the electorate and I
don't think it should I don't care about
any of that the old photos the video I
frankly I don't even really care about
governor Northam jeer book photo where
he's which is actually a very bad photo
it's him either wearing blackface are
more likely wearing a KKK hood but I I
care what he's doing now I care if he's
discriminating against people now but I
don't care about this gotcha thing from
fifteen years ago I mean I I I do care
about the hypocrisy but I don't care
about the thing itself I don't care
about these gotcha politics I mean this
has been we were talking about yesterday
and what we're talking about today this
could be a way to loosen up that tyranny
of the internet that tyranny of images
that tyranny of big tech and we we have
to break up the power and credibility of
big tech we have to do it we can do it
corporate death by a thousand cuts
that's fine for me we can't do it fast
enough and we should do it through leaks
inquiries investigations prosecutions
lawsuits anything and everything we have
to break that up you know big tech makes
our life incredibly convenient it really
does the Facebook Twitter Google it
makes life so convenient it makes it so
easy to do research to do business to
connect with friends to do all of that
there is a cost to that the cost is
surrendering your culture and politics
to unaccountable decidedly leftist
corporate masters of the universe
there's a cost to breaking them up to
theirs if we broke up those companies
there's a cost maybe other cost of
convenience maybe a monetary cost you
know nothing in life is free we've
convinced ourselves that oh yeah we get
to use all these great services online
and they're totally free they're not
free there's a cost the cost of your
data and the cost of your culture and
politics you know we've gone on for 20
years now
pretending there's no cost kind of a
similar issue with China
we've pretended that there's no cost to
just importing all these cheap Chinese
goods there is a cost there's a cost in
now they're our biggest creditor they
own all of our debt they have a lot of
leverage over us there's a cost and that
we don't have a ton of manufacturing
anymore because we shipped it all
overseas because we want to cheap
technical there are technological goods
from China there is a cost there's a
there's a cost that now they can
challenge us in the South China Sea or
at other points of interest for us
around the world there is a cost to
those things maybe you got to pay a
little bit more for a t-shirt maybe you
got to pay a little bit more to use some
gadget or to use some aspect of
technology but you've got to do it the
cost is simply too high before we get to
the mailbag I have to talk about Jeffrey
Epstein there this autopsy has now
revealed that Epstein had multiple
breaks in his neck specifically in the
hyoid bone which experts told The
Washington Post is more common in
homicide than suicide one medical study
of suicidal hangings cited in this
report found that the hyoid bone was
broken in only 16 out of 264 cases and
we're talking about hangings you know
where people usually jump off of a stool
and so there's a huge drop and there's a
crack in this hanging Epstein didn't
have that opportunity he would have had
to just basically lean forward from a
bedpost using a sheet and to try to
asphyxiate himself so it's even less
likely that that bone would have been
broken in his case the likelihood seems
incredibly low now the former bodyguard
of his was talking to New York magazine
he's contradicting things that he had
said years ago in an interview he's
saying he doesn't remember anything he
doesn't remember nothing there were no
underage girls he seemed very nervous
according to the interviewer obviously
there's more to this story you know the
this guy you have this guy this former
Russian UFC fighter he's is a really
tough guy who years ago in 2015 in a New
York Maggie interview was saying yeah he
had these teenage girls around yeah I
was telling him not to do that yeah I
was and then now all of a sudden after
this suicide after the death of Epstein
he's nervous he's sweating I have this
image off-camera of Hillary Clinton
there standing with a baseball bat in
her hand like yeah that's right yeah you
don't know nothing you don't know
nothing about what happened
some people her stones
this was a completely accidental suicide
you got to ask me to believe a lot of
coincidences to believe that it's a
completely accidental suicide the two
guards just happened to fall asleep at
exactly the same time for hours and
hours you've got to tell me that the
suicide watch that he was on he was
taken off of that just coincidental you
got to tell me that he decided to offer
himself right at the perfect point of
the news cycle you've got to tell me
that all those very very powerful people
all around the world who wanted him dead
who benefited from him dead just just a
coincidence
you've got to tell me that he managed to
crack this this bone in his neck more
which was B more commonly done in
strangulation than in hanging he just he
just happened to be one of the unlucky
ones oh and by the way he did it by
pulling on a bedsheet on his knees
rather than the way it would normally
happen by hanging that is crazy the
conspiracy theory now the craziest
conspiracy theory is that he just
accidentally did it that he just
accidentally was allowed to kill himself
there's obviously more to this story the
people telling you otherwise are I got a
bridge in Brooklyn to sell them if they
I got a I got a bridge right right
across the river from that jail where
Jeffrey Epstein killed himself
also important news on 2020 an economist
YouGov poll has Elizabeth Warren up to
20 percent that's tied with Joe Biden
Biden's at 21 percent margin of error is
2.6 percent they're statistically tied
this is among all likely primary and
caucus voters we are now getting to the
point where this primary is really
heating up as we predicted it looks like
Joe Biden's best day was his first day
he just steadily is falling down other
candidates are jumping up including
Elizabeth Warren these next debates are
gonna be very interesting cuz you are
gonna see that crowd winnow down very
very quickly you've got all these guys
bado Julian Castro they're desperately
trying to pull their last-minute Hail
Mary plays ain't going anywhere
unfortunately for those guys we're about
to see the the 2020 race actually kick
into high gear and poor ol sleepy Joe
just seems to be sliding and sliding
further down we got to get to the
mailbag but first you were almost out of
to purchase tickets to our backstage
live show next Wednesday August 21st at
the incredible Terrace Theatre in Long
Beach California go check it out we're
gonna have a ton of fun over there it's
gonna be obviously me the daily wire
god-king Ben drew
there might be a few more VIP ticket
packages go check it out I'm not not
certain that there are but definitely go
check it out we'll be chopping up the
winners and losers of politics in pop
culture
best of all answering your questions
from the audience go to daily wire.com
slash backstage and get it today there's
going to be meet and greets there's
gonna be premium seating photos all
those kind of opportunities go over
there they're selling out fast daily
wired.com slash backstage get yours
today we'll be right back with the
mailbag
here we go I'm gonna fly through this
mailbag from Shannon Michael I was sad
to see that the name Fredo
is considered an ethnic slur that has
been my husband Alfredo's nickname ever
since we've been married
it's a name of endearment all of his
friends call him that
as well why do people think it's a slur
is it just because of a movie reference
thanks Shannon yes it's just because of
the movie yeah Alfredo the nickname for
alfredo is Fredo it's the same name is
Fred or Frederick and our Alfred then
the name in itself took on this kind of
connotation of a weak or stupid guy
because of the Godfather but it's not
commonly used I mean I know I know
plenty of people named Fredo it's the
not a not an uncommon name it's kind of
the same way I mean they're trying to
turn it into an ethnic slur the same way
a name like Paco Spanish name like Paco
is now used as a kind of slur for
Hispanic people but the comparison
doesn't hold up there there are a lot of
terms for Italians I could go I mean I
could name a dozen ethnic slurs for
Italians right now one of them is not
Fredo that just isn't you know to use
one example there's a phrase [ __ ] that
you use for Italians or or [ __ ] [ __ ] is
even probably them the better example so
[ __ ] there are all these different
etymologies for [ __ ] does it mean without
papers doesn't mean without Passport no
it actually comes from the Neapolitan
word Guapo which is just like guy dude
you know hey buddy hey fella [ __ ] oh and
so from that you get the word [ __ ] that
comes out of it is the word Guapo a
terrible word in and of itself no but
it's used and become a slur against
Italians the same has not happened with
Fredo Fredo is an insult for idiots not
for Italians and it's a perfectly fine
name so just go on calling your husband
Fredo no big deal from Jonathan what is
your opinion on the separation of church
and state
thank you Luke I'm very keen on keeping
the church away from or I'm very keen
rather I'm keeping the church protected
from my state and keeping the state out
of the affairs of my church
we have in this country a First
Amendment that does not establish a
religion so we have a history in the
United States of religious pluralism the
first people who came over here on the
Mayflower wanted to practice their own
puritanical version of Protestantism
there were other varieties of that that
came over which established their own
colonies you had Maryland was a Catholic
colony marylande all these different
groups come over and because of that
religious pluralistic history we have a
history of religious toleration and
plural it pluralism in the United States
but the fact that we don't establish the
church in the United States does not
mean that were some kind of secular
country like the people who insist on
the separation of church and state would
would suggest and by the way there's no
such thing as a perfect separation of
church and state because the state is a
religious institution the state has
elements of religion to it the nation
has certain sacred things that it holds
together the I mean you can just look in
our so-called secular culture today we
have a full-on religion we have secular
saints like Martin Luther King Martin
Luther King fine fine guy I'm not
knocking Martin Luther King but the
image of Martin Luther King that has
been created in the American Civic
religion is in many ways a different
figure than the actual man himself
Martin Luther King when you go to the
National Mall speaking of dr. King we
have lots of monuments and memorials to
great American figures those what is the
Washington Monument look like is it just
a statue of Washington no it's a giant
bizarre Egyptian obelisk that's a
religious icon
what about Lincoln's memorial is it just
a statue of Lincoln's stand and they're
giving a speech no it's him sitting like
a god in a greco-roman temple that is a
religious idea we have to hold certain
things sacred I mean we have an American
creed here we have oaths of Allegiance
pledge of allegiance we have common
holidays we have a secular liturgical
calendar we have Black History Month to
celebrate a particularly festive Black
History it's not actually celebrating
Black History but its celebrating this
this particular ideology of oppression
we have Women's History Month again same
thing it's not celebrating Women's
History it's celebrating a particular
ideological view of women's history then
we have Pride Month I mean we are
celebrating pride which is actually the
queen of all sins that gets its own
month to be consecrated and celebrated
on that calendar I'm not even knocking
it because nature abhors a vacuum and
man has religious longings and at the
bottom of our politics is culture and at
the bottom of that is religion and so we
are going to turn our religious longings
toward something and historically in the
United States that's been toward
Christianity or a version of
Christianity and now increasingly it's
toward a version of secular liberalism
or leftism but we're kidding ourselves a
even I who I think I'm I look very
realistically at what the separation of
church and state means and what not
establishing our church in the United
States means but even for people who
think we are gonna have this firm hard
separation they just need to understand
it's not possible and you will worship
something you will venerate something
you will consecrate something the
question in our politics is what are we
going to consecrate from Timothy
recently on ben shapiro sunday special
you mentioned that you speak several
languages what languages do you speak
and how did you come to learn them so
the only languages that I actually speak
I have a very firm grasp on our English
depending on the day the week and
Italian which is why I'm allowed to say
all of those Italian awful ethnic slurs
like Fredo and it's okay because I'm in
the in-group so I learned Italian
actually in school I learned it from the
age of 11 onward studied it in college
I'm a big fan of Dante and Picacho and
spent a lot of time reading Italian
literature I didn't really speak it at
home growing up I'm gonna hear words
here and there and some dialect but
there are a lot of studies that show
that heritage learners are just learn
the language of their heritage much more
quickly than say if I wanted to pick up
Swahili or something and this is
specifically true not for the children
of immigrants but for the grandchildren
of immigrants because they want to not
lose a culture that that is quickly
going away particularly for immigrants
so I picked that one up my French is bad
my lat
is worse I did study Esperanto when I
was in high school it's a language that
you can learn in 10 lessons though I
haven't read it in 10 years I'm sure
I've forgotten all of it and one way
that I try to make my Latin better as I
go to the traditional Latin Mass so I
can incrementally get a little bit
better with my Latin but the nice thing
about learning a Romance language is
once you pick one up fairly well you can
sort of understand a lot of them if I go
into a Spanish Mass I can understand
almost all of what's going on and so
highly recommend it people in the US
don't learn a ton of languages but when
when you learn language I think more
than really any other educational
endeavor it really expands your mind and
not just because you can read different
literature but because you understand
symbols and meaning in a different way
so highly recommended and you should
learn more languages better than I do
because I was a little bit derelict
enough from Devon hey Michael the
national debt and the spending deficit
continue to be a problem for the u.s.
spending seems to have increased under
the trump administration and Republicans
don't seem to care about it anymore if
you were in office and had the means
what would you do to balance the budget
and pay off or at least begin to pay the
national debt what cuts would you make
or what departments would you eliminate
Thanks big fan of the show first thing I
would do I get elected I would get a
nice caterpillar wrecking ball I would
take that down I forget if it's 14th
Street or 15th Street
I would abolish half of the EPA wouldn't
abolish the whole EPA but they have a
giant humongous I wouldn't give them
warning either by the way I would just
go I would knock half the building down
and let half the people fall out onto
the sidewalk and then they can go get
other jobs I would leave I don't know
half or 1/10 of the people in that
building then I would take my
caterpillar wrecking ball to the IRS and
that whole that whole building is gone
there's not going to be a bit of dust
left the people I left at the EPA I
guess they can go do some of the taxes
or something at the IRS then I would
take that caterpillar wrecking ball to
the Education Department you know what I
would do I'll give you one guess that's
right I would take the whole thing down
I would eliminate quite a lot of these
superfluous federal agencies that have
been created in the last 40 50 years the
and I would do it as not because I hate
the environment love the environment not
because I hate education I love
education not even because I hate
taxation I do hate taxation but it is a
necessary evil what does the Education
Department do tell me what it does
can anybody - I I can't I can't seem to
get an answer on that what does the EPA
do I understand supposed to protect the
environment but practically that's not
what it does it usually just makes it
harder for business to operate it does
nothing it takes away people's property
rights and it doesn't actually protect
the environment so I would do that
almost more from a matter of personal
liberty than saving money because even
if you knock down all of those who
wouldn't save a ton of money though it
would help the economy stimulate the
economy by taking away those burdensome
regulations the only way to actually get
the debt issue under control is through
entitlement reform you have to change
the massive entitlement programs
Medicare Medicaid and Social Security
they are not sustainable at the moment
for people who say well I've been paying
into it good for you you're not going to
get anything out of it so you you do
have to reform those there you have to
reform them in keeping with demographic
changes with age changes and and to
stabilize programs that were unstable
from the very beginning that's the only
way to do it it's a third rail in
politics there was a moment in 2010 220
I don't know 2012 2013 when it seemed
like conservatives and Republicans were
talking a good game on entitlement
reform Paul Ryan tried to do it nobody
wanted to do it in President Trump I ran
on the platform of I'm not going to
touch entitlements so I don't think
that's going to happen anytime soon we
knew what we were getting I mean we knew
that when we voted for President Trump
he had his priorities elsewhere he's
done a very good job on most of those
priorities so I don't even really blame
him for it he was at least honest about
it but if you do want to get deficits
and debt under control particularly
these Ivy China because China is our
biggest creditor you're going to have to
make hard decisions when it comes to
those massive entitlement programs and
the trouble with those programs is once
you set them up it is so impossible it
is nearly impossible to reform them or
to pull them back Ronald Reagan said
that a federal program is the nearest
thing to eternal life on earth and he
was right
Carl hello Lord of the cesspool of hate
which is what Media Matters called us my
question to you is how should one
respond to militant atheists who say
it's impossible for stories in the Bible
to have happened like Noah's Ark and
other parts Oh what part I mean what are
you talking about I guess is the real
question that it's impossible for
stories to have happened what's their
story what's their evidence we know that
much of the Bible is historically
corroborated many aspects of the Bible
are so you can point to all those
historical moments not just in the Old
Testament but in the New Testament - I
mean we the life of Christ is well
attested to and in other sources that
are non scriptural so you can point to
that but you could also point out to
them that the Bible contains genre so
it's not all a history book I don't even
know if it's mostly a history book the
Bible contains poetry the Bible contains
parable obviously Christ speaks in
parables I don't think people think that
the book of Job is a history right where
God and the devil are duking it out over
over this one poor guy Joe but that
doesn't sound like a history to me so I
would point that out to him and what it
seems to me when people come out and say
that the Bible is all nonsense it was
written by a bunch of idiot illiterate
farmers or something is I say well what
what's your view of the world because it
seems to me that the Bible contains more
historical poetical philosophical
theological truths on and on and on than
anything ever written and it's endlessly
nourishing and it's there there is
endless wisdom that comes out of it
what do you have you have some like
stupid book by Christopher Hitchens you
have some like cheap book made in 2005
that doesn't even do what it says it's
going to do doesn't even answer its own
thesis that God is not greater that
religion is terrible or something that's
crazy
the the line that comes to me always is
from dr. Johnson all shallows are clear
shallow thinking is clear you know and
the people who say the Bible can't be
true I suspect they haven't read the
Bible and this comes from a school of
resentment which is what the literary
critic Harold Bloom calls
people now are taught because of
ideology to approach works of literature
or history or texts hating them saying
how I'm gonna see how this is sexist or
how this is racist or this is bigoted or
that's off and you so you go in hating
it but really maybe you should approach
it from a position of humility and awe
and then say what can I take out of this
I think it was John Stuart Mill who
described the difference between the
radical and the conservative the radical
in the form of Jeremy Bentham the
conservative in the form of Thomas
Carlyle and he said they they the
radical and the conservative approach a
received opinion or a tradition or work
of of text or art or whatever and they
look at it and the radical says is it
true can I through my one narrow vision
of how this could be true is it true and
what the conservative does he looks at
and says what does it mean what does it
mean what is the book of Genesis mean I
assume what your friend is taking issue
with is some of the book of Genesis I
dare your friend to find me a better
description of human nature and history
and civilization and how we came to be
in the book of Genesis ask him if he can
find one if you can't think you're on
good footing that's our show we got more
to get to but ran out of time I will see
you on Monday in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show see you then
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer
Austin Stephens editor Danny D'Amico our
audio mixer is Mike Cora Meena hair and
makeup by Jesuit alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh oh we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation